i did a reality show for a little bit
after i was done and
you know i think as soon as you start
like pulling back and like kind of
shielding yourself some like people
really want to get into that and figure
that out and know more do you notice
with reality tv reality tv is very scary
to me it's an interesting thing i feel
like it that that is a world that really
digs and tries to like
gets really manipulative um
do you uh
do you think that reality tv like
do you think that being a celebrity and
being married in like in a celebrity
kind of relationship is that a lot more
pressure on a marriage than you think a
regular marriage or do you think it's
just kind of grandfathered in after time
and you get the
hang of it um i think i think it can go
either way i think it definitely puts
pressure
um
on the relationship because you you want
it to be portrayed a certain way on film
and that and that might not be reality
and i think that's where it gets a
little little little little
fuzzy
because
you know you're you're doing this on
television and then like you know it
it's rainbows and sunshine and like
that's not really real life for the most
part like right you know there's highs
and stuff but like
real life can be
married in real life like it there's a
lot of boring times it just is what it
is like you can't always be
you know riding sky high yeah um after a
certain point it's like all right you
know you're married and it's just
you know we're just we're living
together you're just sitting around
you're just waiting for you're sitting
in the car waiting for your wife to get
in the car yeah i mean you go to dinner
like you can do fun stuff but like
there's other times where it's like yeah
we're just
we're just living life like it's just
it's a another it's another wednesday
yeah yeah sebastian maniscalco does on
his instagram he does a lot of uh
waiting for his wife yeah i love his
instagram yeah his is almost like that
that to me a lot of times feels like a
real reality show absolutely it's him
like stumbling through the packages at
the door and like being like which one
of these and that's like real everyday
life yeah um so yeah i mean reality tv
it's it's painting a picture that
isn't always necessarily true um
and i think it kind of skews the
audience a little bit but i mean that's
what reality tv is there for you know
it's fair for drama or for
whatever you know all those things yeah
yeah i mean i think about why some of it
i look at i think i i want to just
sometimes i i remember
especially when i was like
kind of growing up i guess or maybe
like i've made a little bit of money but
i'm not i'm not like a real rich guy but
i remember i wanted to see some of the
kardashians because i wanted to see what
it was like if somebody was rich you
know sure like if they had like
you know indoor pets like that kind of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
you want to see what people are doing
you know i remember that
but um
do you feel like it can do you feel like
that had any effect on like your real
you got your relationship and i'm not
trying to get in your relationship but
do you feel like that like
that can rat like
i just don't i'm really untrustworthy of
that kind of stuff so even the side
effects of a lot of that momentum and
what's glamour and stuff like that we
can start to believe it oh absolutely
yeah i mean and you start to you start
to believe it and you start to think um
that's how it should always be and you
know and you know it's the grass is
green on the other side like all those
things can someone can fall into that
trap
i didn't fall into it um
but it definitely could happen
and it's
you know and
reality tv doesn't bother me and i would
i'd go back and do it again for sure
and if someone came to me with an
awesome reality tv show idea i'd i'd do
it i mean i've got no issues with it
it's just i think you have to be really
grounded in kind of who you are and what
you want out of it right and and and
realize that hey this is this is a job
period
and and your life has to be in a stable
place and and you have to realize all
right when the cameras are gone like
it's just normal life again yeah
which i'm sure is hard for some people
yeah i would bet probably i mean i bet
it's almost like in some semblance the
same of like be you know doing football
or doing something for a long time and
then being out of this like yeah
but it's almost even different because
you're not you don't get to like
not hide behind a game but you you're
playing within a a vehicle football it's
not like it's you
standing out there like and you just
yell out some secrets at the line and
then uh you know the offensive lineman
turns around and tells you a secret you
know it's like but i mean people get
people get confused by this stuff
because it becomes their sense of self
like that's who they are right and
that's what you do for a living that's
that's not what
that's not you that that
you you if you're if your validation is
through
that stuff
that's eventually gonna go away like
you're going to be lost and you know
some people it takes them a little bit
to figure that out and find out like all
right how do i get validated you know
what who am i like what makes me
tick and yeah it's it's a
and i think that's pretty common for a
lot of people i'm sure within their jobs
and within kind of who they are
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one